you have Muslims being forced to eat
pork drink alcohol
the Quran pretty much you can go to jail
if you're reading it if you're saying
assalamu alaikum peace be with you why
are we just allowed to leave why can't
people go in and talk to the people
so that in itself if China you know what
in the summertime if any woman is
wearing long long sleeves did you see
those doctors disappear did you see
those doctors being killed or a skirt
past her knee a skirt just past her knee
foreign
yes how are you good brother how are you
alhamdulillah
it's good to uh finally meet up with you
I heard you're doing some great work
your human rights activist
s YouTube brother I followed you for
many years the dinsha everyone loves you
obviously and subhanallah it's nice to
finally see you mashallah nice to
finally meet you we heard some of the
good work you're doing and you're out of
Australia correct
I'm I'm I was born and raised in
Australia I'm currently residing in
Turkey Istanbul but I work in Bahrain so
I'm across three countries now how did
you get involved we hear the headlines
we read the news we see that there's a
modern day Inquisition happening and
people are just asleep but you're
bringing to light some of these
atrocities that are happening uh women
getting separated from their families
from their husbands being forced into
marriages you have Muslims being forced
to eat pork drink alcohol uh the Quran
pretty much you can go to jail if you're
reading it if you're saying assalamu
alaikum peace be with you and ironic is
this also happening to the Christians
out there
to both Muslims and Christians or just
the Muslims so the issue is far deeper
than just Islam uh the we have to talk
about the actual geographical region
which is it's we we refer to as East
turkistan and it is the land of the Urus
um so Islam makes a big part of our
culture of the weaker culture so for
many many years technically uh Muslims
in general when we talk about Hui or
Chinese Muslims they live
they normally live freely within China
but even they since 2018 have been
oppressed in the manner that you've
mentioned but it's predominantly it's
predominantly happening to the uighur
Muslims and the other turkic minorities
such as kazakhs and kyrgyz uh in Chinese
hockey parties turkistan uh when you
talk about other groups yes there are
Christians that are also persecuted
uh they are not allowed to practice in
their own way the only sort of Islam or
the only sort of Christianity is allowed
to be uh portrayed uh is the state-run
Communist versions of Islam or
Christianity and this has been well
documented you can literally type in uh
synthesized Islam or Chinese version of
Islam into Google and you will see how
they try to reinterpret re-translate the
Quran and make it um a communistic
version of it is it true now that you
have over 2 million plus
Muslims that are in some specific type
of camps can you tell us about that
so according to the most conservative
estimates around 1 million upwards of 3
million but what was interesting was one
of the Chinese spokespeople uh Victor
GAO around this time last year was on Al
Jazeera and said that the uygha
population is six to seven million
people however according to Chinese
statistics and you you can do this
research you can Google it right now the
uyghur population in China or in East
turkistan by official standards is 11
million
and so for him to blurt out six seven
million we worry there could the numbers
could be around 5 million now the car
the camps are separated into four sort
of groups the first group the most light
where you have people go to like work
they go from nine to five they get
educated meaning they are told they um
they are propagated they are forced into
renouncing their religion
and to accept communism as their
religion and to accept Xi Jinping
instead of Allah as their lord now the
second type of uh concentration or
detention are the infamous concentration
camps that we've seen where people go
into these places arbitrarily they are
they are not sentenced
um and they spend
any anywhere between some make it out in
a few months they're allowed to leave
and others have remained in there since
uh it's opening it's a
uh since they've been opened and there's
others where they're actually sentenced
to lifelong uh prison sentences
sometimes 10 years sometimes 20 years
um and it's very arbitrary that they
actually don't go through any sort of
trial period or they're not sentenced um
and there's no documentation it's very
all right you prayed all right for
example seven years uh you uh you were
giving nasiha to someone so even saying
something like for example brother don't
smoke it is Haram see that one statement
that could land you maybe 10 years in
jail it's very arbitrary there's no
actual rule book as to this crime or
this reason this suburb gives you this
many years just don't know and it's not
even Islam there are some people who
haven't practiced a day of Islam in
their life they probably don't even know
how to do Salah even these people are
taken into camps so as I mentioned
before it's not necessarily that you're
simply Muslim but you are also just by
nationality group so so uh how do you
pronounce that again
so in in in my language you'll say
Yeah in the western English are they
normally
yeah uh the land which the Chinese refer
to is officially called the xinjiang yes
autonomous region now the uyghurs
themselves had two independent States
before the invasion of uh the Chinese
Communist Party one in 1933 we
established the uh East turkistan
Islamic Republic that was short-lived
and then 10 years later uh we
established another East turkistan
Republic which lasted for five years but
that was dissolved with the help of
Russia so in 1949 uh the Communist Party
said you know what uh we don't want
these uyghurs revolting against us again
let's give them some sort of autonomous
region and we bought into it so
technically autonomy means you um you
have a leader and you you run your own
Affairs but on paper we actually don't
have any autonomy so in 1955 we were
officially called the xinjiang
autonomous region and um if we did if we
were given real autonomy there would be
no Independence Movement today so this
oppression hasn't been happening for the
past three four years it's been
happening for it especially under
Chinese Communist rule for 70 years and
varies for Chinese nationalists before
that and other under the Manchu Empire
so especially the uyghurs and the
Chinese for a good 260 years have been
at each other's throats
now is it true that we're hearing
stories of women Muslim women are being
forced out of their legitimate marriages
with their husbands and forced to marry
someone from the Communist Party from
the Chinese parties yes this is true and
as I mentioned you know Islam uh what we
are one of the groups within China that
haven't assimilated into the the Han
Chinese say Society because Islam plays
a big factor in that and so you would
rarely ever see uh wig is marrying into
uh non-muslim or with high Chinese
people this is a way that they eradicate
the household So what had initially
happened was uh when the when the camps
were going Full Throttle they initially
locked up most of the men
then you had all the women and children
left at homes then you had 1.1 million
Chinese spies Chinese officials were
forced to live with these women
and they were they were in essentially a
spider how do they live what language do
they speak at home do they pray do they
read Quran then we had a lot of rapes
right this is what initially had
happened now the most recently
especially for the last year or so now
they are publicly asking for their hand
in marriage and if you're if you reject
this
um you too will go into a concentration
camp or the rest of your family will
especially their Elders the these women
our women are being given as ranima as
bounties
for for the hard-working Chinese
officials that have done a very good job
at locking up the weakers so we're at
this stage and now you they on Chinese
state-run media they publicly now
advertise we need uyghur women you know
I I've seen some of the the
quote-unquote say Halal dating apps for
example and you know how you guys
advertise you know Muslim men if you
want to marry Muslim women it's the same
sort of thing but the Chinese government
are actually they've got like a dating
agency running you know state-run dating
agency if you'd like to speak yeah but
how can they get away how can they do
this I mean so how do they if they're in
a marriage how are they forcing these
women to do this I mean and getting away
with it
well no one's doing anything about it
one you have to if you don't you end up
in prison even for example
um
for example uh I've spoken to form a
concentration camp detainees who were in
The camps while they were in the camps
uh they they didn't memorize one of the
for example if you're in a madrasa okay
and you read one of the ayat incorrectly
um you know your teacher will stop you
read that again maybe properly so the
same sort of thing uh happened to one of
these women
that that they wouldn't recite one of
the the propaganda lines properly to her
the official and she got beaten and
automatically she said Allah you know
she could be Allah ah you still have
something in you so she she was sent to
another level of Education to to even
get that out of Allah out of her so you
not bowing down to any of these requests
because they they request they come very
nicely but it's actually a command so
they ask you right now if you if you do
not accept this then you are taken away
you disappear
so let's go step by step uh you you made
a video bringing some of these things to
light and you talked about I mean it's
just hard to imagine or believe I mean
because we're giving certain freedoms to
practice this beautiful way of life uh
Islam submission to the Creator not the
creation you know which teaches us to be
upright and honest moral human beings
worshiping the one and only creator of
the heavens and earth and now all of the
tenets of it I mean starting off with
reading the Quran you're talking about
you can go to jail for that uh saying
peace be with you assalamu alaikum you
can go to jail for this is what you were
saying in your videos is correct uh what
are what are some of the other things
like growing your beard for instance
wearing hijab trying to go to Hajj try
speaking the the language that the Quran
was revealed in Arabic
it was and and you went down a whole
list of different things
it's just hard to imagine how is this I
mean
really really happening
it's it really is happening
unfortunately and um even the people
um who have you know very little contact
still with their loved ones they can't
even write for example we just had Eid
they weren't even able to say Eid
Mubarak
so any sort of religious any sort of uh
you know religious uh inkling is
um oppressed for example there was a
video released on durian now doing is
the Chinese version of tick tock and you
had a man talking to the Rain
he said you know oh rain take us away oh
rain let the let the Earth shake oh rain
um you know that there's nothing to
fight for anymore why don't you just get
rid of this but we understand the
subliminal message there was he was
reaching out to Allah
so he so instead of using the word Allah
he used all rain or rain or rain so like
as you mentioned simple terminology like
assalamu alaikum forget hijab long
clothing if you are in the summertime if
any woman is wearing long long sleeves
or a skirt past her knee a skirt just
past her knee this is illegal that
they're thinking that they are she
actually wants to put hijab and and this
is this is the most she can do so the
the beard even the mustache you know in
the Sunnah we are we're taught to trim
the mustache and grow the bean even
because because the the mustache uh the
weakers are a turkic people and like
Turks culturally they put mustaches so
um the even the cat like Nika used to be
allowed you would have like a religious
ceremony and then you would get an
official government uh marriage paper
but a lot of the things that the the
oppressions or the restrictions that
you've just mentioned used to be allowed
so this was coming slowly and slowly and
slowly people used to be allowed to go
to Hajj people used to be so what would
happen is China would would give you
three four years of ease and then
another three four years of lilim of
Oppression another three four years and
so to to separate the people but now
they're targeting they're targeting
anyone and everyone so for example some
people were given permission by the
government to go to hanch
and later on they were punished
for going to Hajj so they were given
permissions to do these things even
simply going to the United States or to
Turkey or to Egypt for Education you get
put into a concentration camp so any
form even the most you know owning a
sejada a prayer mat anything I mean I've
made the claim that
even to be honest and I'm sure you agree
with me Israel does not do this to the
Palestinians you know in Israel the
Palestinians can still fast can still
pray have hijab they can teach their
kids Quran they can speak Arabic they
can do all these things and um yeah so I
just like to put it into into that
context so you were saying that women if
they have their dress up below the knee
showing modesty they what would happen
to them
um one they're either humiliated on the
street and they have Chinese officials
going cut cut up their skirts and you
can find these images all over social
media simply just type it into Google
and you'll find them if they're not very
difficult to find uh or they are taken
away for education
because Islam is seen as a religion uh
sorry Islam is seen as a disease now if
you are sick brother the first thing you
do is you go to a doctor look uh doctor
I I'm coughing as there's something
wrong with me the same thing if there's
any sort of religious inkling that they
can see in a person uh this person needs
to be cured
this person needs to have this tumor and
this is out of the leaked documents that
were found last year that they describe
Islam as a tumor as a disease that needs
to be removed and these are the words of
Chinese officials themselves the reports
that we're getting that all this is
happening you know forcing people to
drink alcohol eat pork to dress it
modestly uh pretty much eradication of a
systematic
attempt to eradicate the religion of the
Creator Islam where are we getting these
reports are these first-hand reports
coming from people uh do we have and
you're you're obviously somebody who's
creating awareness of this where where
are we getting most of this information
from
from
from social media images so people uh on
the ground
they've taken pictures from bus stops
from government buildings and and if
you've seen my video I put those up and
these are plastered all over the walls
of East turkistan in the public uh in
the public Arena number two I've I've
post I've personally spoken to people
that were locked up for religious
reasons uh for example in 2007 they were
locked up simply for simply for running
a little school in their home or four or
five people teaching the people Quran
but nowadays as I mentioned it's You're
simply we go it doesn't matter how
religious you are anymore uh and so we
have uh we have had uh journalists
uh interview people uh
in East turkistan but covering their
faces and they themselves uh told us of
this as well and and um yes
yeah so
um and from Chinese League documents as
well the leaked documents that came out
if you if you simply type in Chinese
League documents a lot of this
oppression of the Banning of the Islamic
restrictions you can see as well we saw
some of these videos uh journalists from
here going over there and exposing these
camps we've also seen lines of Muslims
in in pretty much uh covered up in in
Mass black hoods what was it and and
being marched somewhere in these camps
so those have been exposed but why isn't
we don't see much of this uh being
broadcasted over mainstream media I mean
it seems like the world is asleep to
this
one it's the access I mean many of us we
do have access to Myanmar to Syria to
Yemen and you can get into these places
to to Palestine you can get there you
can get I mean there are media teams on
the ground but with China they don't let
anybody in journalists are not allowed
in
um and even if journalists go let's just
say brother you wanted to go
every time a journalist goes and tries
to make a documentary tries to interview
the people that they ended up follow
being followed by 10 15 20 police
officers so so the whole documentary
ends up changing into how they were
followed throughout the whole time if
China has nothing to hide
why not let people in I mean the un uh
Western countries have requested China
uh to let them in to to go there
um and to talk to the people okay but
they don't allow this so even just from
that
uighurs are technically Chinese citizens
and they used to get Chinese passports
and leave to and fro to countries as
they pleased no uighurs have passports
now they've taken their passports
they've taken their passports away
so why aren't uyghurs allowed to leave
why can't people go in and talk to the
people
so that in itself if China you know what
if we were to say all right China don't
believe me let's not believe the US the
US is making up all these lies because
it's in the US's self-interest to lie
about China or why don't they let people
in
but
when they do let people in it's not like
they don't let people in at all when
they do they are on stage tours they are
shown the best parts so so they take
them to these schools and they call them
re-education or vocational schools and
that they are re-educating the youth
because their uyghurs are not
intelligent well let's look at some of
the people that have gone missing and
that are in these camps you have doctors
you have professors you've got deans of
universities you've got footballers
you've got millionaires you've got
people that used to work for the Chinese
Communist Party regime for 30 years on
the verge of retirement and some that
have already retired these people the
weakers don't need education the some of
these people had two or three homes
you know these are rich people they were
sending their kids to the United States
to Turkey to Europe to study this is not
about educating the people at all they
know the Chinese language
that um
so yeah
what is what are some of the other
Muslim majority countries uh do they
know about this obviously and what are
they doing to try to stop this
eradication of Islam and oppression
modern day inquisition of the uh Muslim
there
so
since about 2012 2013 China has
you know come across to the Middle East
um and made you know multi-billion
dollar deals with Saudi Arabia with the
gulf countries with turkey and um
they've essentially Pakistan they've
essentially become China's client states
and they don't utter a word
uh you we would get a few statements of
condemnation from here and there from
Turkey for example but from the um from
the more stronger uh Muslim majority
countries we don't
um hear any words of support and instead
we get those Muslim majority countries
even the leader of Palestine Mahmoud
Abbas supporting China and you can see
this in in the video and you know what
China actually supports the Palestinians
against Israel so it's the the the
Chinese are very foxy or very that they
they play this dirty game where they
where they'll be the where they'll rub
shoulders with the leaders of Muslims uh
but
in their own borders uh they are
oppressing them like nothing else on
Earth
what about the United Nations what are
they doing uh about this they're
supposed to be people who are
establishing some sort of peace and
fighting for justice and against
oppression I mean they obviously know
what's going on what are they doing the
UN itself has it in itself been uh is a
client entity of China now I mean
perfect example look at the World Health
Organization
how how they've uh come up to China and
rub shoulders with them the word Health
Organization is a part of the UN the UN
has played no role
um in uh I mean they've requested to go
in but they haven't forced anything
um and essentially China is running the
show in the UN and we've seen this not
just with the uyghurs but uh with
regards to many other issues whether it
be the environments and
other economically as well so pretty
much all these organizations are pretty
much compromised there's big great
complex conflicts of interest and
they're not actually doing what they
were organized and made to do it seems
like exactly well why was the UN set up
in the in the first place so that
another Holocaust does not happen and we
are seeing another Holocaust in the
making
um the only difference between the first
Holocaust and this one is that we we
don't see people being put into gas
Chambers and exterminated on a whole we
see something more because at least if
the uyghurs were dying this would be
better they'll be put out of their
misery but they are being tortured in
these camps they are being fed for 500
calorie diets uh they they are being
their their blood is being taken and uh
our women are being sterilized and they
are being injected with all sorts of God
knows what
um you had a reporter not so long ago by
the name of CJ wellerman and he has
reported on Halal organ harvesting Halal
organ harvesting is when they take the
organs of the uighur Muslims and they
are sold to the highest bidders in the
Middle East
so it would be better it would be it
would be if they just killed us
but but but this CCP machine is more
sophisticated than than the Nazis
because they found a way to benefit to
profit from the uyghurs whether it be
their organs whether it be now they're
being fought being put through forced
slave labor where they are where uyghurs
are forced to make our Nike shoes to
make out out of this bags to make our
Samsung fridges uh a report by the
Australian strategic policy Institute
said that 83 Global Brands were directly
or indirectly involved in slave labor
so this is like this is like you said
this is a modern day Holocaust
Inquisition and it's just very sad and
tragic to see that people are asleep the
world is asleep I mean if you just look
at all the the women I mean if we if we
have if we see what's happening to our
sisters out there who are being raped
and being forced you know people there's
no such thing as forced marriage you
cannot force a woman against her will to
marry someone in Islam and people
usually attack where are the people now
to stand up for these women's rights for
the human rights organizations are there
any on the ground or any who are making
noise who are out there when something
happens on the world they say pray for
such and such pray for such a but I mean
is there a mass movement to create
awareness and to get the word out of
what's Happening of this Inquisition
modern day Holocaust is happening to
these innocent human beings who our
lives are being affected men women and
children in China China is trying to
eradicate
uh Islam out there
yeah as I mentioned there is no one on
the ground you you know how you can
donate to Syria or donate to Palace and
the money will go to the people on the
ground this doesn't happen there there
are no uh human rights organizations on
the ground everyone is on the outside uh
whether it being Europe or the United
States
um and we are TR and I work with these
organizations uh like the week of Human
Rights projects uh like the world of
Congress
um uh the the world American Association
there are a campaign for uyghurs there
are many out there
um doing their best to Advocate uh my
organization the uygha Revival
Association uh so we Advocate Advocate
Advocate but there's no there's only so
much advocacy that you can do
um we really want some sort of you know
Western military intervention I mean
it's it's been done before you know we
have to really do it again
uh is there any collaboration in this
for instance with because you said also
Christians uh to what extent obviously I
think there's there's more Muslims but
there's also a smaller big community of
Christians that are also being being uh
oppressed so would this be a good joint
effort from Christians and Muslims to
come together to try to work together to
eradicate this uh modern day uh
Holocaust Inquisition that's happening
in China by China
yeah so in China I'm sure the Christian
population is much larger than than the
weaker population
um but
yeah but but they're from the the
Chinese population the uyghurs are
predominantly 99.99 uh Muslim
um and there have been various articles
written where you know certain Christian
leaders are put into prison but the
Christians are not rounded up like the
like the Muslims and uh being put into
concentration camps
um
yeah so on the outside we do work with
different groups uh we do collaborate on
certain uh issues but the collaboration
isn't as strong as we'd like
um but uh it even even uh a lot of the
Jewish Community uh standing up for the
uyghurs because they realize hey that
happened to our people 75 years ago this
is a a repeating of History uh but
yeah well we just need anyone and
everyone uh regardless of whether you
believe in any superpower or not to save
human beings because that's what the
weeks are at the end of the day it's a
human effort and uh I've seen that no
matter what political aisle you're from
and what religion you're from The uyghur
Plight has really United the left and
the right and we saw that with the
weaker Human Rights bill that was passed
uh around a month ago where it was a
unanimous
um uh a unanimous vote within uh the
White House where the left and right
came together and all of them supported
except for one Senator
um passing the weaker Human Rights bill
and that has played a big role they've
sanctioned certain Chinese officials
they put economic sanctions on China but
whether or not uh China will secede to
that we'll see because they've gone
ahead and you know sanctioned a lot of
your politicians like Marco Rubio Ted
Cruz Chris Smith and the likes
so what do you advise people to do what
can people do to make a change of
difference what what can people who are
watching uh it saddens their heart it
breaks their heart but they're like what
can I do to help
well number one uh make Dua obviously uh
reach out to Allah
number two social media uh talk about it
uh tweet about it share about it
um if you're a university student and
you're going to write a paper you know
if you're studying politics write about
China talk to your professors organize
rallies within universities
um see if your University is linked to
any sort of uh Chinese Tech firm because
a lot of the technology that I use to
catch the uyghurs whether it be the AI
technology the cameras
um the certain Chinese apps see if your
University if they are tired talk to
University about boycotting stop
boycotting these apps start petitions uh
get creative with it you can do so much
um you know team up find out if uh find
out where your nearest Wego organization
is see what they're up to donate dollar
boycott Chinese Goods
you know because most likely uh if you
see a made in China especially a cotton
shirt eighty percent of the cotton
coming out of China is from East
turkistan so most likely if you're
wearing a made in China shirt your shirt
came from there most likely from slave
labor a lot of things you can do what
about the uh just a couple more
questions what about the Chinese people
themselves I know that Bosnia they have
a open Visa policy where they don't need
a visa to come in you see a lot of
Chinese people coming tourists taking
pictures and I've tried to talk to some
many don't speak English to those that
do some many are scared to talk but the
few that I've taught spoken to they talk
about that this is just propaganda that
it's not happening so what's the
situation with the actual Chinese people
are there some who are also because when
the human see being good human beings
see Injustice they should spend stand up
and speak think about it so what's with
the average Chinese people and what
could they do and are they speaking up
or are they also manipulated by their
mainstream media
one they're manipulated by their
mainstream media and number two they
can't speak out I mean they can't even
speak out against their own government
for for what's been happening with the
virus let alone human rights issues I
mean did you see those doctors disappear
did you see those doctors being killed
did you see those
um uh citizen journalists on the ground
when that when the when the CCP virus
when the coronavirus first came about
and how they just disappeared and they
were talking about a health issue let
alone human rights so the Chinese
themselves are oppressed not as
oppressed as the uyghurs but they
themselves have been oppressed for many
years by the Chinese and and they know
what's up they know what's up but they
cannot speak themselves
um and many do buy into the Chinese
propaganda
um and so
we don't expect Chinese people within
China to speak out against this because
this would be it's impossible
um because of the media blackout for
example if let's just say we were in
China and we're sitting together having
a cup of tea we literally would not know
if there was a protest a block away and
there are protests all the time
happening in China against the Chinese
regime but you simply don't hear about
it people are locked away executed and
you and if this doesn't just happen to
the weeks it happens to the Chinese as
well
I don't see anything in the future I'm
as far as what you go against God the
Creator Almighty you become you pretty
much they're waging a war against the
crater the heavens and the Earth
so inshallah the help will come I really
want to thank you for creating awareness
we're trying to do our small part but uh
hopefully China will take heed and
change their ways because they've
actually declared war on the creator of
the heavens and earth and we know what
happens when you do that it's only a
matter of time
exactly
yeah any uh closing comments or uh
anything else how could people get a
hold of you if they want to contact you
and
yes so um you can follow me on Twitter
at our Salon
a-r-s-l-a-n underscore he diet
h-i-d-a-y-a-t I'm the General Secretary
of the uygha Revival Association
um we have our Facebook page talk is
turkistan uh we're the most popular
Facebook page uh highlighting the uygha
issue in the English language follow us
there
um and just share our things um if you
can donate a dollar and have the
conversation if you don't have
um if you don't have exposure on social
media have this conversation with mum
and dad have it with your friends you
know talk about it in your community
Town Hall meetings all of this matters
do your bit
and for us I mean really take heed and
just appreciate and be grateful for the
blessings you know it just astonishes me
when many of us you know we we're
ungrateful for and we take Islam for
granted but when you hear of these
things you know where they're really
literally trying to eradicate this D in
Islam China trying to eradicate it now
reading Quran the things that people we
stay away from they can't even open up
the musaf right but we have it every day
we're not opening it up praying making
sajdah you go to jail for making such
time praying right hijab you try to wear
it they're forcing you to wear mini
skirts uh at drinking alcohol uh they're
forcing you to do it and you got uh so
many other examples there it's just
crazy we need to appreciate the
blessings that we have and really
Implement our Deen so that our duas can
more likely be accepted and we could
really be grateful for all the blessings
that God Almighty to create our law has
given us and this is a great reminder
for that and just continue to make Dua
for all those who are suffering
all over the world especially here
yeah
um uh and my advice to uh brother you
said it perfectly
um just because all of these things are
happening all those restrictions
no one should think for a second that
the Iman has left the heart I'm sure
people are worshiping in their heart
even though they cannot worship um
physically uh you know the no regime can
you know get rid of get rid of Islam uh
just like this because Allah promises
that this will have this will go on
until the day of judgment and uh yeah so
you'll be judged accordingly it reminds
me we've seen in the past I mean history
just repeating itself they tried to
eradicate God out of the systems and in
this institutions these Communists
happen in Bosnia and this in the Balkans
but what happened at the end it's been
eradicated it's got it's gone and the
belief was still like you said in the
hearts of the people and that Reigns
Supreme
yeah yeah thank you brother thank you so
much for being with us uh may God
Almighty the Creator Allah reward you
for all your work and helping to uh
bring great awareness uh for this for
the suffering tortured uh oppressed
people uh the Muslims in this part of
the world thank you brother
may Allah and make the dean show you
know inshallah your ticket to Jannah
because I've been following you for so
long and um you do such great work
I mean thank you my brother thank you so
much and if you like this episode of the
dean show like this video
share this video far and wide and
support us on our patreon page so we can
continue this work thank you for tuning
in peace be with you assalamualaikum